part of the mission statement here at
the Pioneer has always been to seek out
awesome and unusual forms of training
and exceptional examples of human
performance to that end we really can't
ignore shaolin kung fu in fact I only
don't understand why more athletes
aren't turning to shaolin kung foo for
inspiration in many ways these are like
real-life superheroes they can do things
like standing on their fingers in a
handstand or taking blows to the head
with weapons without flinching or
throwing chopsticks through sheets of
glass and these aren't just one-off
flukes these are practice a ball and
repeatable training methods that any of
us can learn from and adapt into our own
training so let's take an in-depth look
at the secrets of shaolin kung fu okay
so before I go any further I should
address the rather large elephant in the
room that is that a lot of people who
watch this will claim that shaolin kung
foo has had its day that it has no
practical application that there are no
martial monks left they baseless
assertion on the fact that shaolin kung
foo is not a part of MMA that no shaolin
monk has stepped forward to take on
trained fighters and demonstrate the
usefulness of their art but this is
really to miss the point you see shaolin
kung foo is not actually a fighting
style first and foremost it is a means
to an end that end being enlightenment
and meditation and knowing oneself the
story goes that bodhidharma noticed that
his monks were wasting away that they
were so weak from meditation neglecting
their physical health that they weren't
able to focus on their meditation that
they were falling asleep
whilst they're supposed to be focusing
he rightly identified that body and mind
are interdependent and that you can't
strengthen one without strengthening the
other and therefore he needed to
introduce some form of physical training
to his monks therefore he came up with
the 18 lohan hands and sinew
metamorphosis so the 18 low hand hands
would focus on external power and
strength and health and sinew
metamorphosis would focus on internal
health and strength and these would go
on to become shaolin kung foo and
Shaolin Qigong respectively and these
two things combined with meditation are
considered to be the three living
of Shaolin so as you can see then it's
not all about beating the snot out of
people it genuinely was designed
originally as a form of kind of moving
meditation and a way to strengthen the
mind and body and you can't really deny
that this does work the fact that you
can see these people doing head Springs
performing incredible feats of
flexibility or like I say doing a
two-finger handstand really should be
enough to demonstrate that there is
definitely some virtue in what they're
doing does this mean that a Shaolin monk
could beat a trained MMA fighter
absolutely not and in fact most Shaolin
monks would admit as much themselves
these are generally gentle people and
fighting in tournaments for cash and
fame doesn't really sit well with their
philosophy in fact Master Wong cuke it
says that none of this is really worth
all that much in a martial application
without actually practicing in real
fight he admits as much that isn't to
say though the techniques themselves
aren't valuable though or that there
isn't some kind of martial application
to strengthening your finger to the
point you can jab it through someone's
neck there obviously is so rather than
just write it off as hokum instead maybe
we can learn from them and take the bits
that apply to us and integrate them into
our own training and if you're
predominantly interested in health and
fitness and calisthenics and bodyweight
moves and gymnastics and there's a ton
to learn here so one thing that anyone
can benefit from when it comes to
shaolin kung foo is their flexibility
training they use 18 styles called
tongzi gong which is basically a form of
Qigong focusing predominantly on
flexibility and bending and contorting
into unusual shapes this is the kind of
stuff you see where they lift one leg up
by the head and then fall flat on it
that kind of thing again it's kind of
superhuman circus act contortionist
levels of flexibility they train this
long with their quickness and their
lightness their quickness they practice
by performing the same movements over
and over again this is classic martial
arts by rote learning their forms they
become quicker at executing those
movements at the same time they stress
the importance of keeping your breathing
consistent at the same time when you
have to deliver lots of punches quickly
they point out that many fighters when
they punch quickly will become exhausted
and out of breath they practice focusing
on their breathing whilst delivering
those punches quickly and that's where
they emphasize the correct belly
breathing from the abdominal
for lightness what we refer to as
agility they use something called the
plum flower formation when training here
they start by drawing five circles a
foot in diameter each on the ground in
the shape of a plum flower they'll then
perform their moves their forms and
spire etc while staying within those
circles in order to train their footwork
and agility over time they'll then
shrink the circles they then replace
those circles with upside-down bowls
that they stand on top of and then
finally they replace them with poles up
to about seven foot high and this is
where you see them practicing on the
Shaolin poles of course this is
excellent for training their lightness
of foot their agility their balance
balance being something that's very
important in shaolin kung fu' they also
have another training method called
through the woods where they stand among
the poles and try and move quickly
between them and perform forms and
strikes etc without touching any of them
most of us won't want to invest in seven
foot poles stuck in our gardens although
I would love that but what we can do is
take some bowls turn them upside down
and balance on those so that's a great
way of doing something similar to
Shaolin training at home likewise we
could mimic leave through the woods
technique by hanging rope from the
ceiling anything like that tongs II also
includes positions and forms for
lightness and I really like the idea of
using a form made of poses as a way of
practicing balance and calisthenics but
the skill that the Shaolin monks are
perhaps best known for is their ability
to harden their body and take blows and
strikes to that part of the body without
flinching we've all heard of the iron
palm technique where they can smash
through rocks with their hands there's
iron finger there's iron arm where they
can take blows to their forearms
snapping sticks and things there's iron
shin of course iron head iron shirt or
they can take blows to the body and the
way that you train this is actually very
simple once again it's just a form of
progressive overload basically they all
cause a small amount of trauma to the
bones just enough to trigger regrowth
and cause it to come back thicker and
stronger without being too traumatic
that they actually injure themselves
we know that the bones are plastic in
the same way as the brain and the
muscles using a process called
reabsorption and then reversal they're
able to basically break down the matrix
and then build it up thicker and
stronger I made a whole video on bone
strengthening so check that out I'll put
the link in the description and that
will give you more information on how
that works
my granddad actually used to have me
rolling Ratan sticks up and down my
shins we have this cool like animator
relationship yeah hurts more than you
think it does of course Shaolin monks
also name for slapping their hands into
buckets of sand or ice water you can use
any kind of firm surface you can get
things you can hang from your wall as I
have fill it with sand and then as part
of your incidental training see my
previous video on that you can just
punch that every day to harden the
knuckles hardening the knuckles is
actually really worthwhile if you are
interested in fighting because that's
only a weak point and in a real fight
many people would break their knuckles
right away but actually any kind of book
or even just a wooden floor performing
knuckle press-ups all of that will do
the same thing Shaolin monks will then
apply a concoction called deep dark gel
to the area to encourage healing and
speed progress one recipe for this can
be found in the complete book of Shaolin
I literally don't know what any of that
means but iron palm iron shirt iron head
they are not the real secret techniques
when it comes to Shaolin training
Shaolin considers there to be three
different types of force soft force hard
force and a combination of both so soft
force is the quick the light the loose
strikes and perfect technique
that we see when we practice our forms
the hard techniques of things like iron
shin where you can kick a tree a million
times until your shins are so hard and
powerful that you can just plow through
things the combination of both is
something slightly different and here is
where the Qigong comes in handy so I
actually studied Tai Chi for a year and
here we did chi gong at the end of every
single session
Qigong looks a little bit like Tai Chi
it involves holding poses for a long
time and then moving gently between them
and as you do this you visualize energy
moving through your body so it sounds a
little bit strange but stick with me the
idea recording to the Shaolin monks and
kung-fu practitioners is that you're
channeling Chi and that's what you're
visualizing you're channeling it going
through your body and your breathing
correctly and they're supposed to be
causing this kind of holistic health
effect obviously Chi is not proven by
science there's no research out there
backing it up likewise there's no
evidence for meridians being blocked etc
and so we might call into question how
useful something like Qigong actually is
but then we see the guys stand on their
fingers and we realize that they must be
doing something right
so much more impressive than the iron
palm for instance is the
cosmos hand which sounds ridiculously
awesome
so basically where's with the iron palm
you might hit a pile of bricks and smash
through all of them the cosmas hand
would allow you to hit the top brick and
then only break the bottom one leaving
all the others however many on top of it
intact likewise the ironshirt technique
you can kind of cheat by just using lots
of attacks on your own body and deep
dark owl but actually if you incorporate
the visualization you can upgrade this
to a much more impressive version
apparently we can repel attacks with
blades and things essentially it's by
applying this visualization aspect but
they believe you can really upgrade this
into something superhuman so if we don't
believe in Chi how might we explain
what's going on here well one
possibility is that by visualizing in
this way you're actually strengthening
the mind muscle connection and this is
just a theory of mine but I think it
makes a lot of sense I'll use an example
in order to illustrate what I mean
so in Shaolin kung-fu and in Tai Chi and
many other internal martial arts one
thing you're often told to do is to
focus on the old Dan TM this is supposed
to be the center where you collect the
most of your Chi energy and by focusing
on that you're supposed to move from
your center which gives you more power
the Dan Chan is located a few
centimeters below your navel which also
happens to be your center of gravity and
that's no coincidence so now let's try
an exercise often used in martial arts
so we're going to do is find a sparring
partner and then ask them to try and
push you over and as they do focus
either on your head or just focus on
whatever and they're making it of how
they do then you're gonna repeat the
experiment this time you're gonna bring
all of your focus all your attention to
your Dan chant to the center of gravity
and you'll finally find it much harder
to push you over and there's nothing
magical going on here of course by
simply focusing on your center of
gravity you'll bring your attention to
that and you're able to balance more
correctly at the same time there's
probably unconscious things going on
using stabilizing muscles you might be
lowering your center of gravity slightly
it's just a useful tool to help us
concentrate in the right way to improve
the way we're using our bodies and we
can see some interesting analogues for
this all over fitness and martial arts
for instance when you're trying to bench
press if you want to really perform your
very best
imagine that you're throwing the bar
through the ceiling as hard as you can
obviously don't let go you just
visualize that's what you're trying to
do
many people find this technique helps
them to exert a little bit more force
again there's nothing magical going on
here all you're doing is changing your
intent building up your will and thereby
able to recruit slightly more muscle
fiber it's the same thing when you
concentrate on your glutes whilst you're
in a squat in order to become more glute
dominant rather than quad dominant just
by switching you're focusing your
attention you're able to improve your
technique and your performance and your
strength even the key are the spirit
shout and martial arts can be explained
this way in martial arts is described as
helping you to exert more force and to
startle the opponent and actually what's
happening is because you're shouting
you're creating a surge of adrenaline
and studies shown that simply by
shouting when lifting weights we
increase our strength by up to 31% so
you are becoming stronger and it is by
increasing your mind muscle connection
the perhaps there's no mysterious force
moving through your body but perhaps
that visualization has somewhat
accidentally helped me to better engage
with muscle throughout their body that
might sound a little bit far-fetched
Ingrid by visualizing this stuff they
can strengthen their necks and their
fingers and their heads how could that
possibly work well just to stretch this
idea a little bit further there has been
some recent research to suggest that the
way that there fashio is laid out has
some overlap with the way that the
meridians are portrayed in traditional
Chinese medicine so the fashio or
myofascial is a kind of connective
tissue that acts like a film wrap and
surrounds all the muscles and joints and
even the organs and holds everything in
place what's recently been found is that
it also contains its own smooth muscle
cells and that it can actually
potentially help with exerting force
during movement so what's possibly going
on here is that through visualization
perhaps they're increasing their my
muscle connection to the point that they
can actually engage this part of their
body and there's all kinds of little
parallels and correlations within their
writing in their training that makes it
seem like this is at least possible I'm
not saying that's definitely what's
going on and I'm certainly not saying
that we need to accept every aspect of
Qi Gong I'm not saying necessarily that
we need to accept that she healing is
real for instance I personally have a
hard time swallowing that I'm just
saying that perhaps this kind of
training has enabled them to access
strength and perform with their bodies
in a way that otherwise wouldn't be
possible and that might explain why
they're able to do things like to finger
handstands and if it sounds absurd then
remember that wim HOF basically did the
same thing taking
just control over its own autonomic
nervous system which no one thought was
possible so let's not completely rule it
out and this is also why the focus and
the determination and the grueling
training of the Shaolin monks is such an
integral part of their routine they
train something like three or two hours
in the morning and the same again in the
afternoon after a short thirty minute
power nap at least six days a week
that's pretty intense a lot of this
stuff will involve really grueling
boring work like running up huge numbers
of steps or standing in horse stands for
really long amounts of time by doing
this their building will and
determination from the same time
visualizing their muscle control and so
it's no surprise that they could pull
off incredibly cool feats however they
managed it it seems fair to say that
Shaolin monks through sheer grit and
determination have managed to achieve
some kind of insane control over their
mind and body and we should definitely
give them props for that and we should
consider learning from them where we can
and maybe incorporating some of these
ideas into our own training certainly
I'm gonna be researching this a lot more
there's a whole lot more to Shaolin
training that I haven't had time to
cover in this video for instance their
training involves pulling nails out of
planks of wood bow ding gong or shaking
down trees Bao Xu Gong or performing
head Springs Gd Gong if these are things
you're interested in you'd like to hear
more about then of course stay tuned to
the bio near subscribe let me know in
the comments down below if there's
anything I missed all you'd like me to
cover in future let me know what you
think of Shaolin training and of shaolin
kung fu' in general thanks ton for
watching guys I really appreciate it and
I'll see you next time
bye for now